was there a blog post or a chapter in
the book that was actually difficult for
you to write so I know it's a
culmination of these blogs they did over
a five-year period right but was there
one that you actually thought oh this is
fine and then you realize you know this
is this is actually affecting me ah
interesting
yeah I think going back to the period
the the slow periods and in one's career
or having having achieved something and
not have the results that you think you
know like well look I
I sold a movie I should be this and the
reality is well no that's not always the
case after I sold my first spec it was
my fifth spec but it was my first spec
that I sold I was at the time doing
catering because I'd worked in
restaurants before I went to film school
and after you know because I always
didn't want to get into a day job where
I would not have any time to write and
so restaurant was good money and it
would free you up to be able to write as
long as you would write because that's
important I was in the restaurant with a
lot of people wanted to be actors and
they they loved playing the role of an
actor but not actually doing the work so
if you're you're given the free time to
do it you better do it and I always did
it you know so but it was the time when
I sold my spec and I was in the trade
papers in a variety and every writer
wants to be in variety right then you
see how I made it right well the day
that I was a variety the headline was
this new company had formed and they
they option my script and they were
going to buy it and make it into their
first movie and that day a variety I had
to do a catering job at one of the
biggest producers in Hollywood's house
and so it was his catering company and
my friend and I drove up to Beverly
Hills and here we're at this giant
mansion of this producer and it was a
big breakfast meeting with big you know
power players former prime minister of a
Middle Eastern country you know security
everywhere and I was thinking wow
you know I'm in variety today why should
I be catering you know and also I was
thinking in a way which is in the book
what if this producer had had you know
rejected my screenplay Here I am in his
house serving him coffee you know so
just be careful about who you you know
disrespect you know on the way up or
down because you know you just might end
up in there in their house pouring
coffee for them you know but that was
hard to write but hey I look back on
that now and laugh you know but it's
it's a reality of the business because
as you know you know it's a step deal so
when have anything sells you know it's
in steps and you may not get the final
steps so when a screenplay sells you get
a little bit of money and then a little
bit of money for the next draft and next
and then has to be made for you to get
the bonus so everyone thinks that just
because a script sells suddenly you're
you know everybody's calling on the
phone and things like that so I would
say that was not difficult to revisit
but you know I think about the time I
put myself back into the time that's all
I was trying to do when I was writing
because I'm a very visual person and I
can really have this sense of memory and
it back in the time it wasn't funny you
know it was very it was like oh my gosh
so now I've done this and still I have
to do this and you're like yeah many
times you have to live in these two
these two parallel worlds and that can
mess with your head a lot so you have to
be really grounded and say this is the
reality of it and it doesn't it doesn't
it's not the image of Who I am I am a
writer if I'm catering or always doing
anything else at the time you know so
you know that I think that's such an
important story because I think people
can be caught in two worlds here for
years
absolutely and eventually some will
definitely turn the corner and and the
the party will be at their house
so to speak to use that metaphor and
unfortunately for some it won't
you